foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Sunday we're sitting around drinking yes
pumpkin chai Porter yeah that's that
O'Fallon and talk about Fallon O'Fallon
fake Irish stuff Fallon oh phallic yeah
this shit's [ __ ] Yankee as hell
[ __ ] it's uh it's good though this is
good actually I like it it's good
it tastes like chai tea tastes like
almost Indian chai tea with but also
beer with a little bit of pumpkin and
it's beer yeah yeah we got an ABC we got
that for our uh Friday night Sidetrack
show where we had all the we were just
discussing like what theme the um the
the liquor or the beer for the next show
is going to be but we'll figure it out
y'all seem to like our the southern
stuff you know that's that's the that's
the regional culture we can that we can
[ __ ] sell to uh to you guys maybe
we'll do some moonshine or something
because actually that apple pie
moonshine that we got that was
delightful some more of that and I just
kind of like found it accidentally
because it was just in the little like
sample bin at the by the uh by the Yeah
that moonshine was cash register it was
actually very good I mean it's knock you
on your ass if you drink like a whole
bunch of picks it was really strong and
it came in a little jar it was a little
bit of Jar I love it so apparently you
guys have been waiting for us to do
Elvis for a really long time I had
actually I remember seeing the trailer
for this a while back
and I was kind of like man that looks
pretty cool I like want to go see that
because I really like baslerman and it's
the thing about it is if you either love
baslerman or you don't because his style
it's um it's a lot you know what I mean
it's a lot it's very blingy it's very
flashy it's very sugary it's very over
the top but if you like that kind of
thing then
it's just you know what I mean I mean
I'm a big fan well you're a big fan of
his Romeo and Juliet yeah and I also
really like that I'm also a big fan of
Moulin Rouge so I was like really really
excited to see this and we watched it
last night I think it's still in a
couple of theaters
um you know just maybe like you know the
cheap theaters and stuff like that but
we actually saw that it was on HBO Max
which I have so we watched it on there
last night because I've been like come
on I've been wanting to see this so at
first Tom was like I don't know if I'm
in the and then he was like ah [ __ ] it
let's watch it and uh it ended up even
though it was it's it was two and a half
hours long two hours and 40 minutes
something like that it really didn't
seem that long to me no it goes by fast
I got like really invested in it you
know yeah I ended up really liking it a
lot
I wouldn't call myself an Elvis expert
when I was a kid growing up they had
Elvis experts that knew everything that
was true about Elvis and everything that
was false about Everest they even knew
all the lies and legends they knew
everything and they just [ __ ] worship
Elvis you know it was it's usually women
and they would read [ __ ] Elvis fan
fiction and [ __ ] this is like for my
dad's generation they were like that
never got like the people that those
would be like the chicks that would
[ __ ] be into Orion and actually
thought that maybe somehow the [ __ ]
Spirit of Elvis had possessed this other
guy from Mississippi sound just like him
okay just like Elvis wore a mask
um
wasn't him though when he took that mask
off all the [ __ ] Mystique went away
but uh he sounded just like him
um but I just grew up with it
Elvis was originally from Tupelo
Mississippi which is probably about 80
miles maybe from Heidelberg where my
family's from Heidelberg Laurel area
area is looking
um
Jones County
it was a wild candy doesn't [ __ ]
movie about it called the free state of
Jones and it's still called the free
state of Jones
fought the Confederacy and the Union
but uh
yeah Elvis I know the culture even
though I didn't live during his time he
died when I was a kid
right right around when Star Wars came
out I remember when it happened
my mom's friend Yvonne and this is when
we were living in California my mom's
friend Yvonne [ __ ] came running up to
the house she was crying I remember
seeing it she was crying she was in her
20s when my mother was like what's wrong
what's wrong what's wrong with you Elvis
died and she's like what and [ __ ]
they turned on the television and they
were announcing it was like JFK being
shot it was a big deal I was only five
when it happened but I remember yeah
being on TV I remember everybody
freaking out I was like Elvis died I
knew who Elvis was yeah I was like he
died you know why I mean I was a little
kid but I didn't except if somebody died
and was was even weird to me
and then
after that
going back to Mississippi
basically my whole life
for Summers you know because my parents
were divorced I go back to see my dad
and you know I grew up in the Laurel
area Heidelberg area
and
people of my dad's generation basically
some of them
almost kind of revered Elvis has as a
Messianic figure
on par almost with Jesus almost is weird
man
it's weird you had to be there to you
had to see it to experience it through
that Through The Eyes of somebody who
really
wasn't a fan to see it you know to fully
appreciate it
and you know they'll make Hollywood
would make movies about it you know but
those guys weren't there for that they
just heard about it you know to make a
movie about Elvis Freaks and [ __ ] in
Mississippi it was [ __ ] big deal but
probably the same up in
up in Memphis and Tennessee you know in
the Tennessee area Nashville because he
actually mostly lived in that area
he moved up north he was born in
Mississippi
listening to gospel music and stuff yep
it was kind of like the Eminem of his
time he grew up in a basically mixed
neighborhood whites and blacks he grew
up around black kids
and
grew up with early dealt Mississippi
delta blues almost prototype rock music
and he was way into that and when he
started playing music he playing guitar
that's what he played
and his dad was kind of an ex-con and
who really couldn't help the family when
he started coming into money it's one of
the reasons why I like this movie is
that it really explains his Southern era
real well about how he was tearing up
the South First any all the clubs around
the golf area and up in up in Tennessee
Nashville excuse me Tennessee Kentucky
area
he was just a [ __ ] sensation he
wasn't National he was local
and um
he started making more money than his
dad could ever dream of so he kind of
became the alpha of the family wherever
he went his family to go with him
and when he went National he just did
[ __ ] that only a southerner would do
from that time I mean he'd go to a damn
movie set and bring his whole family
here meet my Mom meet my dad that was
like really uncool [ __ ]
you know for those even today he
wouldn't do that you couldn't do that
back then really bring your family to
the devil yeah nowadays that would be
weird too yeah be my mom and it was like
bringing your whole family to a job
interview or something like that
so they did kind of touch onto the he
kind of came off as a mama boy to a lot
of people but in Southern Culture
especially old school Southern Culture
he became the head of his family
so they became kind of his
responsibility it was almost very kind
of like something out of Central South
America Italians would really understand
that because they're almost kind of like
Southern old school Southern families
are almost kind of like something from
Southern Italy
where their patriarchies you're taking
care of your family you're almost like
the dawn of your family almost and his
crew was called the Memphis mob it was
kind of like a mafia but that's just
very Southern to Outsiders it's bizarre
but he was it makes a lot of sense when
you when you know those cultures when
you grow up in it I'm sure somebody from
Mexico Venezuela
Brazil you know I grew up I grew up in
Brazil too you know they're about nine
years
um
they understand that you know Italy but
not Northern cultures you know what I
mean they're a lot more atomized you
know
more of an individual culture
Elvis was from the old school [ __ ]
family cultures
yeah I was going to say too that it's
like they do uh mention in the movie
yeah that his dad had gone to jail but I
don't want to make it seem like his dad
was some master criminal or something
like that because it was like some bull
it was like it was Czech forgery yeah
yeah which you know is illegal obviously
brought it over him though but it's a
[ __ ] it's kind of a [ __ ] charge
it's not like he shot anybody or
anything like that yeah it was just some
[ __ ] they were they were poor family
and that's when Elvis was a kid yeah I
don't think he I don't think his dad
went to jail again like later but yeah
they did hold it over him like I said
they were you know his family were very
poor so you go to jail once and they're
like not gonna be like wow that's what
those poor people do can't let them get
away with anything there's a lot of
Elvis movies some of them are real good
each one of them kind of has its own
angle this one has its own angle which I
did like this is from the angle of
[ __ ] Colonel Parker yeah his manager
all right
and it starts off a Parker [ __ ] known
as an old man getting ready to die and
he goes people said I killed Elvis I
didn't kill Elvis I created Elvis you
know and then we you know he we were
partners and then it goes back and
[ __ ] it kind of shows [ __ ] where
Elvis came from and from how Colonel
Parker kind of grimmed him and then how
eventually
okay
I do like this movie so don't take this
the wrong way I do like this movie
um but the movie is really about Colonel
Parker's
Financial abuse of [ __ ] eligibility
yeah yeah I mean yeah I mean well the
thing about it is that Elvis is
obviously so large so much larger than
life that obviously any movie that's
about Elvis is going to be about Elvis
but I kind of like another take yeah I
kind of like that it's seen through the
lens of Colonel Parker because I don't
think that's really been done before
never been done before and I kind of
feel like you know the colonel Parker
character which you know played by Tom
Hanks is clearly the villain you know
what I mean they're not trying to make
you feel bad for him or there's I mean
he's clearly set up as the villain but
it's a really interesting perspective on
Elvis because you're seeing it from the
point of view of a kind of a villainous
like vulture type of guy he was
predatory who sees himself as I made
that guy famous yeah and you know and he
kind of like took advantage of him a lot
I'm not saying he didn't help his career
I'm sure he did at some point but
you know it it's a it was a complicated
uh relationship that they had but I
really do kind of like I thought that
was a really interesting lens to see the
movie through like see it through his
character there are three main movies
that I recommend and this is one of them
this is a good movie
the other one is um the one with Kurt
Russell done by um didn't John carp John
Carpenter yeah he made that Elvis movie
John Carpenter is like the good default
movie it's like the official story it's
just kind of nothing but the facts it's
it's pretty close to what the that's
what the basic story is and the other
one I like
is Elvis Elvis and Nixon yeah and that's
Michael Shannon yeah yeah I like that
one because that one kind of gives you
the feeling of what it would be like to
hang out with Elvis and
how interesting he was he was he was
wild man he goes on a secret mission
to talk his way into seeing the
president
and to be and to be seen as an equal
with the president okay
and become a secret agent all in this
112 one Fell Swoop while he's carrying a
gun into the White House all kinds of
[ __ ] while he eats the president's M M's
well he says yeah you're the president
but I'm the king you know just it's just
bizarre and then you end up wondering
did he really want to be a secret agent
or or was did he just want that badge
it's just not known
but you get an idea of [ __ ] what it
was like to hang out with him at least
just on that one
little Mission because the witnesses
that were with him there survived and
they said yeah that's it that's that's
what it was like
and he was a trip man Elvis was a
[ __ ] trip
um
it was kind of a proto-goth in a way he
knew melon nermy also known as vampire
he evidently liked uh later on in the
60s he liked Hammer horror films and you
can definitely see him and Lisa are
dressed in all that [ __ ] black velvet
with the red and the black hair and you
know they're doing the hammer horror
vampire kinda Motif and some of that
stuff that some of the photos that I've
seen in him he and his decor
how he decorated stuff is he kind of
liked vampiric stuff they said he liked
vampire movies
that's weird
you don't think of it I mean he's been
really weird I mean but yeah vampire
movies yeah you love gospel music that
was really you know I didn't really like
Elvis's music that much but I thought he
was great singer
um but he really liked gospel and I
really like gospel
but I like to Elvis Elvis was [ __ ]
[ __ ] an interesting guy
weird
but in many ways average kind of
southern guy his of his generation
really
yeah well and the thing about it the
thing about Elvis and Nixon is that it's
not I wouldn't call that a biopic
because it's only about a very very one
thing he did it's one thing that he did
like one very flick period of time
whereas this is a biopic but because
it's baslerman he takes a lot of
artistic license yeah now a lot of the
stuff that happens in here is kind of
close approximation of what happened he
did embellish some things he does kind
of like skim over some things
um you know because it seems that he had
like particular
um you know proclivities are things that
he wanted to focus on which is fine
because like I said it's he just took
creative license with the story
um some of it like I said is exaggerated
but not that much you know what I mean
it's just kind of like oh it happened
like that but not exactly or they took a
couple different events and like smushed
them together or something like that I
don't think there's anything in there
that's just completely made up at least
as far as I could determine
um but some things are kind of like
shifted around and stuff but that said
it's like even though
as I said it's two and a half hours and
some stuff is just skimmed over and some
stuff but I do think that it got the
thing I like about this movie is that it
really kind of like captured the essence
of Elvis even if it wasn't even if some
of the stuff that happened wasn't
exactly true it's like I don't know it's
just very like myth-making which I think
was very much part of the whole elbow
thing yeah so I think that was like a
really good way to go about it and can
we talk a little bit about Austin Butler
because [ __ ] did he get the Oscar did he
get nominated I don't know
he totally should have because he got
the dance moves in the voice I was
watching this movie and like halfway
through the movie I realized that I had
forgotten that I was watching an actor
playing Elvis yeah and that's always a
good sign because that hardly ever
happens yeah that hardly ever we got the
dance moves down and the voice and just
he he looks pretty close pretty close to
the way Elvis looked
um you did a great job
um oh a lot better than what's his name
from from uh Elvis Elvis and Nixon that
doesn't look like Elvis Michael Shannon
like I said but he does a great Elvis
yeah he he does a great Elvis and he's
he was pretty aware when he was cast
he's like I don't look anything like
Elvis they're like we don't that doesn't
matter we just want like the essence of
Elvis yeah and this one I think they not
only nailed the essence of Elvis but
they also got the look of Elvis yeah
that dude it's it's weird because they
actually show like some actual footage
of Elvis at the end it's hard to tell
and it's almost kind of like hard to
tell him apart or when he looks
different you know like the last scene
where they showed him where they showed
actual Elvis like uh singing at the
beginning like in the close-up for a
second I thought that it was a
recreation because actually they did
recreate a lot of his shows like Pretty
closely and sometimes you couldn't tell
no they Blended in real food when it was
footage and when it was the guy because
it's just kind of like Austin Butler
just he really like embodied that role
he you never ever get the sense that
he's doing an Elvis impersonation Asian
or a shtick or anything like he comes
across like a real person they got a
scene where
Elvis is down and I think I see I think
it's in Memphis it's either Memphis or
Nashville and he's hanging out with BB
King and BB King they're in the club and
uh BB King's telling him that uh man you
should do whatever the hell you want to
do because you're you're making too much
money they'll never you know they'll
never come after a white dude making as
much money as you you can do whatever
you want because Colonel Parker was
making him trying to make him stop
dancing like that
which is it which isn't exactly true but
I don't think it's true right I'll get
into that a little bit Yeah well it
wasn't so much Colonel Parker doing it I
don't know I'll get into it like I said
I'll get it and then during that scene
playing in the background so dude doing
Little Richard and that dude [ __ ] is
great and he was he was like at one
scene but I was like oh my God that dude
Richard yeah
he was great yeah I don't know what that
actor's name is but he was yeah
he was fantastic yeah yeah he really
really he nailed it he would like to see
more of that
yeah they should now that's the next
movie baslerman he should make a movie
about Little Richard with that guy
Little Richard was [ __ ] Brave as [ __ ]
that's that dude he was out yeah that
time he was out
yeah
but uh anyway after that scene they
started to go down a path that I had
never heard of that's probably what
Jenny's talking about they basically
make it seem like
Elvis got drafted because he wouldn't
stop singing that because he wouldn't
stop dancing that way and I don't think
that's true I think he got drafted like
anybody else and didn't try to get out
of it like other guys who had a lot of
money would have gotten out of it I
don't think they drafted him as
punishment
I don't think so either like yeah they
didn't exactly say that in the movie but
they almost kind of made it seem like
that just because the one scene like you
see him getting arrested for you know
wiggling yeah because apparently that
was illegal back then but yeah yeah you
know what I mean but um and then the
next scene they have a thing where it
looks like you know he got drafted and
they're like well you know he has to go
and maybe this will be a good thing or
else he's going to jail and it's almost
kind of like they were implying you know
it's either go to jail for the wiggling
or uh or join the join the Army but like
I said he got drafted anyway yeah I
actually think they were gonna give him
a more cushy position but he said no
that he was gonna take like the that's
what I always wanted to be a normal you
want to be a normal that's what I heard
too and that they actually they they um
see that's a big part of Southern
Culture is doing service he's not going
to dodge out on that and they made it
kind of look like he cried over having
to go he didn't want to leave his mama
that's not true either
um although his his mom did die while he
was yeah I think he brought her to
Germany with him for a little while
didn't he
um I think no I don't think so she um
well maybe I thought they don't really
show that in the movie but she did die
like um I think she died in 1958. yeah
and he actually did get leave obviously
like when she died and he came home for
like for the funeral but uh Elvis people
were when Elvis went into the army they
showed him getting his hair cut and like
uh his his haters were like oh man that
must suck for him but he was happy to be
there and uh he wanted to to be um in
combat arms and they made him attack her
and he was a model Soldier and uh ended
up making E5 Sergeant I think he was a
tank command driver I think maybe ended
up being a commander I'm not sure I
think it was a driver
and uh
they failed to mention that he met he
met Lisa Marie there and that was his
commanding General's daughter they uh
kind of Glide over this in the movie but
she was only 14. yeah she was young when
he met her in the movie they actually
make it seem like they're kind of the
same age that was not the case yeah he
was 23. that was he and she was 14. that
was normal back then if you had the
dad's permission you could date like 14
15 I think I think yeah they let them
see each other I don't think they let
them really hang out like after like
once she turned like 17 I think they
were like okay you can go kind of like
on dates and she was a fan so she asked
her dad to see him yeah and they were
hanging out
and if you've ever seen any any photos
of Lisa Marie she's probably one of the
best looking women that have ever been
born she was [ __ ] gorgeous
um and they were quite a couple you know
he was just as good looking as her
but now dad said it was cool oh yeah we
keep saying Lisa Marie
Priscilla sorry sorry Lisa Lisa Marie
yeah I was I get a confused Priscilla
Priscilla's gorgeous
Lisa Marie looked a little bit like
Priscilla though you look like her dad
though too Lisa Marie's cute real cute
Priscilla that's right
yeah he just called hercilla I think
didn't he yeah silly yeah
um anyway the uh
so they left that out
and um
when he comes back his his career was
bigger than ever
when he got when he came back I think he
did pretty well they made it sound like
he came back in his career fizzled but
that from that's not how I remembered it
I remember he was he made some movies
and did a bunch of [ __ ] when he got out
of the army and uh made a whole bunch of
money Bill Graceland up and
well I kind of mean it's fun being Elvis
I mean Elvis didn't have a bad life he
had a [ __ ] great life I mean he was
his his his career did start to [ __ ]
take a nosedive in some ways over time
because he became a commercial product
he wasn't really rebellious anymore
there wasn't really anything all that
they made him sound really shocking and
[ __ ]
and he probably was when he first
appeared but by the time though
the 60s had come around Elvis was
[ __ ] tame compared to what was going
what was going on you know well that's
why what I was just going to say was
that when the 60s came around he went
more in a movie like movie after
Direction rather than music but all of
the stuff about him getting threatened
with like arrest and stuff like that for
all the hip wiggling and all of the uh
controversy that he caused like with all
of his you know black moves and all that
kind of stuff yeah
um most of that is true now the one
scene that they have in this which is a
great scene actually where he um they
tell him it's like oh you have to like
tone it all down or you're gonna get
arrested like no hip wiggling no doing
nothing and then he decides [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and he goes out there and sings
that [ __ ] that evil song in our
reading and he's like just shaking his
[ __ ] hips all over the place and then
he gets arrested now that actual thing
didn't happen but they said that's
actually like a like a compilation of
like two or three different uh concerts
where that actually did happen like one
of them happened in Florida and I think
there was like another one where he did
actually get threatened they're like you
can't do that hip shaking thing or or
we're gonna like put you in jail so it's
not at a time like I said it's just an
exaggeration and they kind of like took
a bunch of different events and like
kind of glommed them into one thing but
he totally was yeah in the 50s
particularly he was totally
uh shocking for them because not only
because of the kind of
very overt like sexuality that he was
which wasn't really a thing that you did
but also because he was
doing quote unquote black music or at
least like what old white people
perceived as black music like you know
what I mean it was just so they were
kind of wasn't really it wasn't really
black well it was the new wave of music
and there was blacks and whites doing it
it's just that black people had been
doing it first yeah but delta blues and
they were just making it harder and
called it rhythm and blues and then it
started to become Rock
rock and roll
the interesting thing about it though is
like in this movie they kind of make it
seem as though like I said that
um because of all this rebelliousness
and everything like that like Colonel
Parker was afraid that you know his cash
cow was gonna dry up or whatever so he
said maybe we should do more
family-friendly Elvis and when he was on
TV like they made him like wear the you
know the the tuxedo and like the dog and
everything like that
that did happen where they made him put
on the tuxedo and like sing to the dog
but that was not actually Colonel
Parker's idea that was Steve Allen's
idea who was the host of the show that
was his idea because he wasn't a big fan
of rock and roll so he just thought it'd
be funny I guess but
um the thing about it was that at least
from what I heard that Colonel Parker
and Elvis actually were saying maybe
they should tone down his image or make
him more family friendly because they
thought that by the time he got back
from the army that rock and roll would
be passe little did they know yeah but
they didn't know like at the time they
were just kind of like they thought it
was just kind of like a fat or like
flash in the pan they didn't know how
far that was gonna right they didn't
realize that so they were just kind of
like well maybe we should start like
changing direction like when I get back
I'll be more kind of like clean cut or
whatever but then like you know they had
not seen the Rolling Stones yet I guess
not and the Beatles And The Rolling
Stones [ __ ] changed that that changed
the game
Elvis didn't really like that actually
it's I think that's part of the reason
why he wanted to go more gospel he
didn't like uh Elvis didn't like
anything it was like real hard like hard
rocking like
like he didn't like Jimi Hendrix or what
they call as of rock he called that drug
music you know what do you call it which
is ironic really considering a lot of
pills and [ __ ] yeah but see that's the
thing like even people back then like
you know you could be a 50s housewife
and pop uppers all day long but then you
could on the other side of your face she
could rail about all those dirty hippies
in the asset and I'm like aren't you on
drugs too though it's like that I gotta
know different I got a feeling that
Elvis smoked weed though anyway probably
weed was around we was around in
Mississippi in this they kind of go into
that a little bit like they do kind of
go into how upset he was at um Martin
Luther King and Robert Kennedy and stuff
like that getting assassinated which he
had which he was it happened like in
slightly different timeline than they
show in the movie but it's you know not
that big a deal but um I do kind of feel
like they don't really get too much into
how he didn't really like like all the
60s music that was coming out so much
because he
um you know there's a scene where he
kind of approaches uh who Colonel Parker
thinks of as like hippies that are like
at the TV station to kind of like kind
of go more in his own Direction because
he feels like Colonel Parker is like you
know has his you know foot on his neck
or whatever like too much and he wants
to kind of go back to his roots and kind
of do his own thing and uh Colonel
Parker like kind of castigates him for
like hanging out with all those hippies
and radicals and [ __ ] like that but they
like I said they don't really go into I
feel like Elvis and Nixon goes more into
yeah into what he into how much Elvis
didn't really like also that 60s Counter
Culture yeah that was just politics see
uh the thing the thing I liked about
Elvis and Nixon is they showed actually
how
traditional how patriotic uh Elvis was
he was
very Mission oriented he was very much
kind of like a uniter
uh he he would sing songs that would
have The Battle Hymn of the Republic and
[ __ ] Dixie in the same song and he's
trying to merge north and south and
black and white and trying to get
everybody to to come together to save
the the country because from Elvis's
point of view it's the 60s it's flying
apart he he thinks the Union's going to
break apart into a big Civil War
basically that's what he's imagining and
it was kind of a civil war of a type
it's just it wasn't catastrophic well a
lot of people thought that a lot of
people thought he thought the Soviet
Union was behind it
he's not the Soviet Union was shipping
in a bunch of mind-altering drugs like
LSD and stuff and uh and that he thought
he thought that maybe the Rolling Stones
and the Beatles maybe were Soviet
sympathizers and that maybe they were at
least maybe according to that movie it's
hard to say
but he didn't yeah that might have been
slightly exaggerated or he might have
told Nixon that because he was trying to
get a one-up on his on his competition
too you know it might have been Brown
knows it's hard to say it's hard to say
what Elvis thought Elvis was
um was an intelligent guy very gifted
but he's very much
a southern man of his time
and uh
he was
he was a conservative he was not a
radical he was a conservative it's just
that it was his ver his version of
conservatism he was trying to
trying to keep America together he
wasn't trying to he didn't want to let
it be blown apart into a revolution
well I think in his early days he was
maybe seen as more subversive because of
his Embrace of quote-unquote black music
and introducing that to a white teenage
audience which a lot of people you know
back then like parents and stuff did not
like yeah so they saw that as
particularly subversive
yeah that's what I mean for him it
really didn't seem like he wasn't doing
it on purpose he was just he grew up in
that area he grew up in a very poor uh
part of Mississippi he grew up hearing
black gospel music and delta blues and
things like that and he was just doing
what he liked yeah this is just good
southern music from good people and he's
trying to uh play it for everybody
that's what he liked and other people
liked it too or he would have failed so
yeah he just it was just about quality
and he sang in the black churches and
did a lot of gospel he actually liked
gospel personally yeah that's kind of
what and they kind of go into that in
this movie too like after like once the
60s came along he kind of wants to go
back in that direction because he said
that's the music that made him happy
yeah so he kind of wants to go but he
kind of does his own spin on it
obviously but that's kind of what he
wanted to go back yeah his later stuff
from the 60s and 70s is All gospel yeah
and really
um even though
man Life as a as a Vegas singer
really beat him down and yeah somebody
mentioned earlier that um he did
something like 700 something shows like
and they do show that in this because it
does seem like and the movie portrays
this like I said they exaggerate some
things about it but he did actually kind
of a little bit get talked into slash
shafted into
um doing these performances at that
place in Vegas the international or
whatever it was called and what it was I
don't know if they said this in the
movie but it's it was one it was a one
month engagement like every year so I
guess it was like I don't know it was
like every night for a month or five
nights away or whatever it was so it was
just kind of like every year he had to
come back and do like a whole month or
six weeks or whatever it was
and um I don't know
and they do kind of go into this too
because you were saying like before we
got to this part of the movie where you
were like I don't understand why Elvis
never went like overseas like tutorial
Germany or Japan and this movie actually
does go into it and most of the stuff in
there is pretty accurate like at least
from what I could determine
um Colonel Parker did not want to go
overseas because he was an illegal Dutch
immigrant and he did not have a passport
he didn't have a he didn't have an ID he
didn't have an identity because he had
like a fake identity for so long Colonel
Tom Parker was not his actual name he
was a Carney yeah in the Carney in the
carnival and uh just he he played Carney
games on Elvis and Elvis's family and
they were just sitting ducks for this
guy and the South being a like I said
I've said it many times before
especially the Old South this was a an
honor-based Society it was it's not
League it's not legalistic
they would do things on a handshake or
they would just write some [ __ ] out and
a dude like Parker could talk a family
like that and just tie it into a pretzel
he made a little family business where
he put all the elephants
relatives in these dummy positions with
impressive titles and would pay them out
of Elvis's money and and get all get
them to all become loyal to each other
and the only way that this could hold
together is to keep
Colonel Parker in the loop and when they
fire when Elvis fired him Parker comes
back with itemized all the way from day
one everything that Elvis supposedly
owed him and and on all of Elvis He
could make it look like on paper that
Elvis owed him money
well because I don't know if you guys
know this but Colonel Parker took 50 of
everything of everything which for a
manager is unprecedented yeah it's not
something that you do and today it it
doesn't make any sense
to a modern person of today who has
normal normal understanding of the way
the laws work but you're not that's not
what you're dealing with you're dealing
with an older Southern family that's the
thing that's so funny he had all this
Fame and all this money and Fortune but
really he was just a regular
Southern
dude
from a small town you could bamboozle
Elvis well he'd grown up poor he wasn't
dumb you know how to do it but he didn't
have any experience no experience
anything like that I mean what's I mean
and I'm not [ __ ] it's like I don't
either I grew up for it too I don't I
wouldn't know what to do if I won like
me you could have brought in you could
have brought in a Hollywood lawyer or a
[ __ ] lawyer from from from New York
would have walked all over Parker all
right and Parker would just would have
been set down the road with nothing all
right but they never did that I never
did that well because I kind of feel
like At first like Colonel Parker was so
effective in like weaseling his way into
their good graces that I kind of feel
like Elvis almost kind of felt bad like
he didn't want to like tell him to
[ __ ] take a walk yeah I mean it
really took a lot before it was emotion
he had him yeah by emotion and I think
that he didn't want to think that this
guy that he knew forever he would betray
him right so I kind of feel like he just
played on that weakness right now
another thing that they showed in the
movie is not entirely accurate they now
Colonel Parker was a Carney that's true
but by the when he met Elvis because I
think in the movie they kind of showed
him still kind of being a Carne or like
meeting Elvis like before he actually
met him
um when he met him
I think it was 1955 and I think he was
already like a talent promoter at that
time like he was already promoted like
Hank Snow they did go into that in the
movie
um at a couple of other kind of like
country western kind of people and then
he just kind of heard about Elvis like
from because he was on Sun Records then
which is like a regional uh label so he
heard about him then
and he's like oh my God like this guy's
amazing so we need to get in on this and
the thing about it was that they kind of
show in the movie that you know they put
Elvis on the Hank Snow show it was kind
of like this country thing they went
around and played fairs and stuff that's
true that did happen but they kind of
show in the movie that Hank Snow was
just kind of like oh I don't like this
wiggling nonsense or anything like that
um it didn't seem like Hank really
bothered with that he was just kind of
like hey man they love this kid so man
let's close the show out with him he's
making all this money so he didn't have
a problem at all like he wasn't
scandalized or anything like that and
actually for a while early on in his
career Hank Snow and um Colonel Parker
like actually co-managed Elvis like for
a little while so there was that too
um because I kind of feel like they made
Hank Snow but you're like oh my goodness
and he's like he wasn't that bad you
know what I mean like he just he thought
Elvis was great he wasn't like pissed
off that he was like stealing his
Spotlight or whatever yeah one of the
things that I was gonna say before
but never got around to it was uh
Elvis really wanted to do gospel and
towards the end of his uh I was I was
going to say towards the end of his
career
he was really starting to get beaten
down
uh I don't think his morale was real
good and I have a I have a theory based
on
what his complaints were he thought
there was something wrong with him I
have a theory of what happened to Elvis
medically okay
so yeah we all know what you're gonna
say yeah okay anyway
um
if you hear if you listen to Elvis in
his final months some of his last
performances he sounded [ __ ] great
even though he's definitely in bad
health
he was starting to sound like Luciano
Pavarotti yeah he sounded like an opera
so getting fat actually improved his
voice quite a bit and he didn't really
improve him as a Vegas Entertainer he
wasn't really the kind of guy that you
went up on stage you know [ __ ] uh you
know
entertaining the women
but he was
[ __ ] a great vocalist his whole life
yeah
um and he never lost that it seemed like
even in his worst Health at the end when
they were kind of like just shooting him
up with drugs which they kind of do show
at in this movie and this is kind of
[ __ ] up there's like because there's
one scene where uh you know he collapses
like in the hallways like this is during
the Vegas uh years yeah and he collapses
in the hallway and he's just like losing
it and Colonel Parker's like you know
shoot him up with something because we
get that man on the stage and then they
ask his dad who is his business manager
now I was going to say too that that
whole Elvis Presley Enterprises that
company wasn't formed until after he
died yeah um it was Colonel Parker and
uh Priscilla and stuff they were
managing his estate like in his in merch
and stuff after he died but his dad
actually was his business manager so
they asked so they asked the dad hey is
this okay or should we take him to the
hospital and he's just like no get him
up and yeah you know they're they're
just trying to show that like his dad
was I don't know if that's true or not
but there is like a scene in there where
that happens so it really does seem like
I don't know like it's the the biopic
it's it's a really interesting thing
because it's just so it's so fizzy and
so over the top and just like so kinetic
and it's just like really fast-paced and
like it's really really beautiful to
look at and covers a lot of like ground
but then it's also kind of like a
tragedy because it's seen through you
you're seeing it Through The Eyes of
Colonel Parker who
kind of [ __ ] him over I mean you know
what I mean
and yeah you could argue that maybe he
wouldn't have gotten as famous without
Colonel Parker I kind of doubt that
um I think he probably would have been
famous anyway just because he was so you
know he just had that star quality I
think someone else would have discovered
him if Colonel Parker hadn't come along
he needed much better management but I
think he definitely needed much better
management because honestly like Colonel
Parker he just knew a chicken that he
then he could pluck it right and um and
it's kind of sad you know what I mean
it's kind of sad that he did and I'm not
saying like Elvis had millions of
dollars and I'm sure he had like a
really good time for a long time but
Elvis needed to be doing real tours at
his age real world tours to keep his ass
[ __ ] motivated putting him in front
of real new crowds constantly let him
play in front of Japan he could have
played Russia all right that's that's
how famous he would the Soviet Union
would have let him in they'd let him in
they'd let him yeah he's [ __ ] healthy
even Elvis right he could have gone
anywhere he wanted to
and that's what's kind of sad about this
movie is that they kind of show that
Elvis wanted to yeah go to all these
places and do all this stuff and it was
almost kind of like Colonel Parker was
like holding him back yeah if you see
films in his later years of him
doing these shows some of them are are
in in uh uh casinos
this is a religious experience for the
audience it's definitely that they
they're just they can't get enough of
this dude
it's kind of funny when he's really out
of shape
but I it's a lot more understandable
when he's still looking really the part
but he was really he could just come off
the stage and get down into a middle of
a [ __ ] huge crowd of fans and it
would part
like the Red Sea and he could walk
through them there's no rock star that
can do that today
no it could never have done that in the
70s or 80s he was literally a king
he they they saw him as a king
he was he was something else
something else but like I said I think
that that's the main I mean as awesome I
really really liked this movie A Lot
Like I said it was a lot of fun it's
long but it did not seem long at all
it's just kind of like kept on going and
it was always something like cool to
look at
um but I mean Austin Butler as Elvis was
particularly in the scene where like the
very early scene where he gets on stage
like with his old band like before
Colonel Parker is even like really met
him or sort of [ __ ] with him and he's
like standing there and somebody's kind
of like heckling him from the crowd or
whatever like hey get a haircut you
fairy or whatever and then he just kind
of stands there for a second and then
all of a sudden he just like busts out
and like starts singing and dancing
around and stuff like that and
it's you know it's kind of hard to like
see from our modern day perspective it's
like you know what was so great about
like the hip wiggling and everything
like that but when you see Austin Butler
playing it like in this movie and like
you see like the way that vas Lerman
like shot all the crowd like reacting to
him and stuff you could totally see how
that would be a thing you know what I
mean because the performance in this is
just so
it's just like electrifying yeah
another thing is is that he also did
some he did a lot of uh Elvis's 70s
moves which Elvis did all these damn
experimental [ __ ] personal signature
moves that would not fly today only
Elvis could do that all right and get
away with that [ __ ] and they're kind of
awkward when you see him actually doing
the Kung Fu yeah doing Kung Fu [ __ ] and
doing weird [ __ ] bird moves and [ __ ]
but he got it down right he got it right
that's that's what Elvis was doing now
um
what happened to Elvis is this what I
think happened to him
I think they I think the Story begins
that he heard a hurt a leg or something
when he was on stage he started taking
pain pills
and uh somehow or another he started
taking pain pills
and he never stops taking pay pills he
started taking more and more of them and
he had a bunch of yes men around him who
would just give him more and more what
he wanted
that's a bad [ __ ] sign yeah you never
a lot of guys Prince went down that way
[ __ ] well anybody if you get to a
sufficient level of Fame yeah uh you're
in danger of that happening to you
because it's the the Richer you get the
more famous you get the more of a bubble
you're in and so the more you only
surround yourself with people who only
tell you what you want to hear or you
know only do what you want to do and uh
that's not usually a good thing I think
he died at 41 42 40 somewhere on that
age
yeah which is Young all right that's uh
if you're counting that's eight years
younger than I am yeah
that's the most damn near 15 years ago
then I am okay yeah that's more than a
decade younger than you are yeah he was
a young man there was a lot there was a
lot of miles left in Elvis yeah if you
looked at him towards the end of his
career you wouldn't think so though
because he was just so out of shape but
that happened like in that last two
years yeah
he wasn't always like that
so the order of order of events that
I've been able to put it together in
terms of the complaints that he had I
saw a program that said that he in his
final
few years he kept complaining about
joint pain that his joints felt like
they were grinding in his knees and his
elbows and he couldn't get down on a
knee to do his little special moves and
[ __ ]
so he did more of these pain pills
to get it done
and the pain pills
helped him put on all that weight too
and this is what I think happened he got
addicted to those pills
those pills are always suppressive
suppressive to [ __ ] natural hormones
including testosterone
but he was able to hold on for a while
until he hit about 40.
and at 40 I believe that those pills had
suppressed his testosterone to the point
where he he hit kind of like early onset
of male menopause where his [ __ ] test
production was probably just down into
[ __ ] dumps
part of the symptoms of that though is
that your your endocrine system isn't
producing a lot of the fluids that keep
your joints
soft or you know I mean inflated so
that's what he's talking about
there's no test in this [ __ ] system
had you got him off those [ __ ] pills
and banged him up with a bunch of tests
he'd snapped right back
he'd have been all right
but that's that's probably should have
got him off those painkillers oh yeah
you had to get my painkillers get him
off but he was taking the painkillers
because he was trying to avoid the
feelings of one withdrawal from him two
the feelings of [ __ ] having such low
testosterone in your system
uh because that that hurts too so but
that it was just that simple
banging up with a bunch of tech keep him
on his pills just bag him up with a
bunch of tests he'll feel a lot better
and then slowly wean him off the damn
pills and then he'd lose all that weight
too the weight was that weight came on
because his metabolism would have been
at a crawl you know his test was so low
no matter what he ate it would have went
right to his [ __ ] waistline
so I think that's all it was and he'd
have been good way into his 60s [ __ ]
look at Mick Jagger
he could have been around forever
yeah I know like I said it's a shame
yeah slasher Fred said one of these days
you should do a review of Bye Bye Birdie
which was also inspired by Elvis being
drafted in the Army we should actually
really like to buy Bye Birdie I thought
I haven't seen it since high school
because we watched it in chorus but uh
let's see I thought there was a bunch of
other uh things that I wanted to address
Elvis they said everybody who knew Elvis
and the mob said that when that was came
back from from the Army he was still
Elvis but he was a military man after
that and he approached things in a
minute in a military fashion he always
carried guns on him
all the Memphis mob head guns they were
all Deputy sheriffs from all these
different counties from a dam crossed
Tennessee so they They Carried guns
legally and a [ __ ] Elvis like [ __ ]
four uh 1911 45 autos and he had a bunch
of them and they were all [ __ ]
dressed up and engraved and scroll work
and just pimped out Elvis love the
[ __ ] bling
he had custom made leather holsters for
him and all his men you know the perfect
holsters all just handcrafted [ __ ] and
just you know they were into real good
guns and they they shot they said Elvis
was really good with a 45 you shot and
he was known for getting [ __ ] up and
shooting out televisions too
if you saw something on television that
pissed him off he'd pull his gut out
[ __ ] shoot that television
then there'd be a brand new television
there for an hour later
but I guess when you got that kind of
money it doesn't matter you just you
have the right to shoot a television
when we were talking about uh the Vegas
thing TV drugger said seven nights a
month for the most part some nights off
some nights had two shows a night okay
night's a week okay that's it that's
what I was thinking I was thinking it
was probably like every night for a
month but in the movie they kind of had
it like six weeks yeah you know what I
mean like he agreed to do it for a year
because they were like hey we can do it
and they'll pay for it because the place
had newly opened and they needed a draw
um but he's like okay but after that I
can go to Europe right and he's like
yeah totally even though he had no
intention of like letting him go over
there it's just I don't know I kind of
feel like
it does kind of the movie does kind of
make it seem like Colonel Parker like
prevented him from going I don't think
he could have like
physically prevented him from going over
there but I kind of feel like he guilted
Elvis into not going because like I said
Colonel Parker couldn't go anywhere
because he was a fake person he didn't
have any ID he didn't have a place
because he was had better a false name
for like a really long time he like
emigrated to the U.S like illegally
because he was Dutch and so he didn't
really have he joined the army I think
and he just used the name Tom Parker
because it was the first thing he came
up with and that's just who he was so he
didn't really have any like [ __ ]
history so he couldn't leave the country
because he was afraid he'd get caught so
there was that too but
I don't know it just kind of seemed like
he was he couldn't have prevented him
but I can see why Elvis kind of got
talked into saying Hugo said Bruce
Campbell also did Elvis and Bubba hotep
yes he did honestly I I love Bubble tab
that's such a great movie we did a
review of that like a long time ago
that's Elvis fanfic it is yeah that's
it's based on it it's based on a story
by Joe R Lansdale if you haven't read it
and the story is actually really good
the movie is a pretty is a pretty close
um
adaptation uh fat Elvis is here and says
we used to make jokes about blue-haired
old ladies but on you it looks good well
thanks I am also a blue-haired
blue-haired old lady
um but yeah so like I said if you're not
into
I don't think you have to be into Elvis
or even know that much about Elvis to
enjoy this movie because I had a good
time with this it's a fun movie like
it's not
there's sad [ __ ] in it because like his
story is ultimately like kind of tragic
but the way it's presented is actually
really fun
and the music is great uh you know
Austin Butler is [ __ ] amazing as
Elvis like I said halfway through the
movie I totally forgot that it was an
actor which that's always a good sign
when that happens honestly I can count
on one hand the times that that's that
that's happened for me in a movie that
like that an actor I recognized
um you know or you know that was playing
a kind of an iconic character like that
I forgot that it wasn't like the actual
person even though duh like the person's
dead they're in there talking about it
talk about devils in Elvis's final years
he evidently was um he couldn't have sex
he didn't feel good enough
so what he would do is he'd have one of
his friends he'd see he'd see some chick
that he liked and he'd have one of his
friends pick her up and have sex with
her so he'd get a full report later on
what she was like that was one evidently
one of the things that Elvis would do
you know you got power when you tell
some other people to have sex give me a
full report in the morning
have it on my desk yeah
like a book report like a book report
yeah what she was like what she looked
like with her name on the front of the
photograph
that's
kind of weird though yeah
yeah he was impotent
uh TV Drigger said my girlfriend ever
cared about Elvis but loved it as a
movie when I saw it the second time the
audience was full of a mixed bag from
old guys to teenagers yeah like I said I
really don't think I mean Elvis is just
such a
ubiquitous cultural figure I mean yeah
less so as like the years go on but
everybody [ __ ] knows who Elvis is
even if you know that much about him you
still do kind of know some [ __ ] about
him so I kind of feel like even if you
really don't know that much about him
you can still watch this and it's still
entertaining you know what I mean if you
have not seen Elvis and Nixon see Elvis
and Nixon all right this is a good movie
too and they also want to see uh John
Carpenter's Elvis
with the yeah I mean this one is a good
one too the thing about it okay so Elvis
and Nixon I kind of feel like that's
more for Elvis fans yeah and history
Buffs yeah yeah yeah because that's a
very specific yeah uh point in time in a
very specific event like our series of
events just something Elvis did like in
a period of a few days and I think
you'll enjoy that one more if you know
at least like some of the contexts
surrounding it so I do kind of feel like
that's maybe a smaller audience uh the
Elvis biopic that John Carpenter did
which is decent and it has the Crustle
yeah
um that's good if you just kind of want
a No-Frills basic version just basic
kind of like this is like a pretty
accurate summation yeah of Elvis's life
and career this one is what you watch if
you just want to lick a big entertaining
flashy stylish
um you know because this is like I said
you don't even have to give a [ __ ] about
Elvis at all uh to watch this movie just
because it's so So Beautiful to look at
I mean like I said if you don't like
bazlerman's style then I don't know what
to tell you because he does have a very
specific
over caffeinated kind of style like
everything is like very quickly edited
and everything's just kind of like
there's we're jumping ahead years we're
jumping back years we're jumping forward
years we're doing this that and the
other thing but if you're kind of into
that I mean I kind of feel like all his
movies are like that so I kind of feel
like if
you didn't like his other movies then
you probably won't like this one either
because it's also like that but I mean
if you like to Moulin Rouge because I
love Moulin Rouge I kind of want to
actually watching Elvis last night kind
of made me want to watch Moulin Rouge
again even though I've seen it like five
times
but or Romeo and Juliet because that's
good too so if you like those you'll
probably like this as well because the
style is very similar and honestly I
think that bass lerman's
style is very kind of like over the top
very blingy style I think it suits the
subject matter very well I think this
was a good match of directorial style
with subject matter and like I said
don't watch it like thinking everything
is a hundred percent historically
accurate because it's not but
they didn't take they took Liberties but
not that many Liberties like some of
this stuff is like exaggerated or like I
said some of the stuff is moved around a
little bit like in time to make things
look a particular way but not really as
much as you might think he didn't take
as many Liberties as as youth might
think so I mean the comment section it
said no Elvis just got drafted there
wasn't anything behind it they offered
him an entertainment job yeah that's
what I said no he wanted to do that's
what I thought and that matches up with
everything that I've heard about Elvis
and that matches up with Southern
Culture he's just a it's just part of
Southern Culture it's a manly thing to
do you do your duty do you time you did
this two years he was supposed to be a
model Soldier everybody liked him he was
very popular and was a good NCO and got
out
and it stuck with him he Elvis wanted to
be a secret agent after that that's what
that that's what that Nixon movie's
about you'd like it
yeah itself as a military man I mean the
thing about this movie like like I said
it doesn't come out and explicitly say
that you know he went into the army
because otherwise he was going to get in
trouble for all of you yeah you know all
of the sexual stuff that he was doing
like on stage and whatnot it doesn't
come out and say that but the way that
it's edited does kind of imply that that
was how it happened but it does say that
he got drafted because they have like
him dropping the thing that like the
draft notice like that says drafted on
it and then them kind of like talking
about it but yeah so it's like I don't
feel it's a little bit deceptive like
the way they do it in the movie but not
you could read it like either way they
don't like explicitly come out and say
oh he got he went to the Army or he got
drafted specifically because yeah you
know they were mad at him because he was
like corrupting the morals of the Youth
of America believe that yeah I believe
that but
I will say that
um they asked Lisa Marie Presley what
she thought of this movie because she
got to go to a screening and everything
like that she thought it was [ __ ]
fantastic okay she thought it was great
uh she thought Austin Butler was amazing
she said that's he really captured like
the essence of her dad which I agree I
mean I don't know I didn't watch the
Oscars or
uh and I well I mean I kind of like
looked at who won but I forgot and if he
wasn't nominated that's sad because he
was amazing in this now I will say I
love Tom Hanks
I don't know if I liked him as Colonel
Parker though
I kind of feel like I wish that they had
got a less recognizable actor like a
less
famous actor I don't know man Tom Hanks
pulled that scum back off I'm gonna say
he did which is weird because he doesn't
play villains a lot if this isn't the
first time he's played a villain like
he's just a scumbag he's played villains
in other movies but um not that many
he's usually like a good guy and he's
like a he's not over the top [ __ ]
yeah yeah scumbag he's just a dude who
thinks he's doing the right thing but
you know everything he does is
duplicitous yeah he's just a duplicitous
man and he seems kind of aware of that
but he's like okay with it yeah he's
made peace with how she's saying he's
not he's basically saying I'm not a
parasite I'm a symbiote okay yes yeah he
needs me we need each other that's
that's what he's saying yeah
that's the thing yeah but one thing that
I've heard some people complain about is
that uh if you haven't seen the movie
Tom Hanks does
I guess the an approximation of like a
Dutch accent because now the guy like
Colonel Parker was Dutch okay but I
don't think that Colonel Parker I
haven't seen like a lot of footage of
the real Colonel Parker but he didn't
have a Dutch accent I would have had a
Southern accent indistinguishable from
any other redneck down in there
see I don't know like I said it's been a
while since I saw any real footage of
Colonel Parker but I don't remember him
having a Dutch accent but Tom Hanks does
have kind of like a Dutch sounding
accent in this movie and I think they
could have done without that probably
would have sounded like any other
cracker like [ __ ] like uh like like
Colonel Sanders Protestant just like
that
yeah and honestly you'd think that him
being a Carney you'd think that he would
do any kind of even if even if he didn't
really talk like that once he was
approaching Elvis and like getting in
that game he would have started talking
like that sure
also I think this movie too like because
I oh I meant to mention this a long time
ago
um showed there was like a super super
close friendship between Elvis and BB
King which
they knew each other but I I don't know
if they like they weren't as close as
they appeared in this movie but they did
know each other though yeah so I so I
don't know how accurate that stuff is
the
the only time or the what do you say the
most famous mention I've ever heard
about Elvis and some of the black artist
was um
uh James Brown
evidently James he he really liked James
Brown and Brown went to Graceland
several times and evidently James they
were gonna they were planning on doing
some kind of a musical project together
when he died you know it was something
in the works that they had that had been
interesting
I don't know if that was going to be
something that at the international or
that have been you know yeah because
they didn't bring James Brown up in this
but evidently James Brown lost it at the
funeral
he was at the funeral oh [ __ ] asked
for guy he got time alone and everything
with the casket and [ __ ] lost it
um
those two were a lot alike James Brown
and and uh Elvis were were a lot alike
they had they were both Southern
Republicans and they had uh the big
Unity at the unity vision and everything
and uh it was very Southern Centric
um they liked gospel
they kind of came Church kind of
background church church choir
backgrounds they were a lot alike they
were both very Alpha too
there needs to be a movie about James
Brown James Brown was [ __ ]
interesting
they say he was tough as Nails I mean
they're you'd think in this era that
there has been one yeah and somebody
will probably tell me Jenny there's been
like five of them where have you been
yeah
I haven't seen any good James Brown uh
[ __ ] movies appear out of nowhere
like like this one you know like it's
like they think the market isn't there
but I bet you James you could hit did
Bohemian Rhapsody and stuff but no I
think James Brown would make a good
topic
I can think of a lot of musicians that
would make like real and you know it's
coming from me it's probably going to be
like niche market kind of stuff but I
mean honestly even even musicians that
I'm not that super into I always I like
musical biopics I'm just you know sue me
even if it's a band of [ __ ] I'll even
watch musical like documentaries about
bands I don't even like all that much
just because I don't know it's just
interesting I find it interesting but
I'm not saying that because I really do
like Elvis but
um I just I don't know I thought this
was like a really really good movie I
kind of feel like
the movie I don't know I didn't really
get a read on how the reviews were going
because I know it's been out of the
theater for a little while like I said I
think it's still playing at like some of
the cheaper movies but we watched it on
uh or the cheaper theaters we watched it
on HBO Max I kind of got the sense that
when it first came out that it was sort
of getting like slightly negative
reviews at first but then I don't know
it seemed like 75 85 percent of the
reviews were positive
um especially because of uh Austin
Butler who the crazy thing about this
Austin Butler I think he's been in some
other [ __ ] but I think this is like his
first big movie I mean I don't think
he's been in anything like substantial
like prior to this and man he [ __ ] I
was really impressed I'm just saying he
just like he [ __ ]
poured himself he committed he committed
to this [ __ ] and I just I thought he was
[ __ ] great I don't know if that's his
really his singing voice I don't know or
if they had somebody else sing for him
but
it doesn't really I mean if he if it's
um you know lip syncing or whatever it
looked really good they just did a
really good job and honestly like I
liked this I think I like this as much
as I liked Bohemian Rhapsody and I liked
Bohemian Rhapsody quite a lot yeah it
was good too I also like yeah they're on
par Bohemian Rhapsody was more a
standard biopic in the sense of because
you know biopics musical biopics
particularly usually have a template
that they follow like I said I like them
so I'm not [ __ ] on them by saying
that but Bohemian Rhapsody was great
because I you know I like Freddie
Mercury and I really like that subject
matter and it was an interesting take on
his life
um but it was kind of like a standard
narrative like a standard musical biopic
narrative this one kinda was but then it
had kind of just like style for days
you know what I mean and whether you
like baslerman style or not that's
entirely up to you but if you do then
man this is all over because even I was
like even watching the end credits going
oh my God even the end credits have
bling all over the sides and everything
like that like this you know the the end
credits are scrolling and there's like
all this gold like [ __ ] on the side and
everything like that I'm like oh my God
I love it I love it they committed to
that [ __ ] aesthetic man and I was
into it
uh TB Drigger said apparently he had
trouble talking normal for a while after
the movie and
as though he was doing an impression or
that he was doing a voice or doing the
Elvis shtick or anything like that he
just came across like a person he came
across like Elvis you know what I mean
he didn't
that's the thing about playing Elvis
it's got to be one of the hardest things
for an actor to do because anything that
you do if you go too far into it it's
almost kind of like doing like William
Shatner or somebody that somebody that's
like really distinctive or has a lot of
distinctive moves or a very distinctive
voice if you do
if you go just that much a little bit
too into it then it's gonna seem like a
parody you're gonna seem like you're
doing an impression and it's gonna seem
you know inauthentic at no point did I
ever feel that yeah with Austin Butler
in this he just seems totally embodied
it doesn't seem like he's doing any kind
of like parody type of thing or any kind
of
he's not doing Elvis this the shtick you
know what I mean he's not doing that
he's just being a person that happens to
be Elvis and I don't know I just thought
it was great I thought it was great
uh you all right yeah oh okay
about time for us to get something to
eat though I guess so holy [ __ ] we've
been going on for more than an hour yeah
I thought we covered we covered this
[ __ ] we covered it we covered it yeah
but yeah it's on HBO Max like I said I
think it's still in theaters like at
some cheap theaters I saw when I looked
it up earlier but like I said if you're
not real into like over the top real
flashy like basilarman's other stuff
then you'll probably hate it but other
than that I would recommend it I thought
it was great um because I like baz
Lerman so you know what I mean uh but
yeah I liked it a lot okay so tomorrow
is Monday which means that it's a
haunting Mondays so we're gonna be
talking about an episode of Haunting
let's do do you want to do the calling
yeah that was the one we were going to
do because somebody recommended that one
before and that was the one that I
thought was the one that we did last
week that was called Damon's revenge or
whatever the [ __ ] so we'll do the
calling which I think is season four
episode three or season three episode
four I'm not entirely sure but it's one
of those two things I'm pretty sure so
uh unless if if something changes I'll
post it and I'll post it anyway but I'm
pretty sure we're gonna talk about the
calling tomorrow so if you want to watch
that episode before we talk about it
tomorrow then feel free to do that so
have a good rest of your weekend you
guys and we will see you again tomorrow
evening good night